oh this one's gonna grind me into the
dirt so I came into this month after
having done a video a day in May
thinking I'm gonna space everything out
and they have decided to just dump
trailer after trailer after announcement
and supposedly there's even more
trailers coming out in the next couple
days
and it's not it's not like I feel
pressure from my subscribers to talk
about other stuff but the thing is a lot
of this stuff that I wanted to talk
about even because it's really good or
it's really not so I get to rejigger my
entire plan schedule but that's just me
complaining the lego movie to the second
part so the lego movie was good it was
great even and it had no right to be
absolutely none and even more impressive
they've stretched that concept out
already like a Batman movie was great I
think I might even like to put a more
than the original lego movie but they're
both great Lego DS jogo was good not as
good as the other two but it was good
and I I have become so skeptical of
trailers like I have not trailers of
sequels lately especially in regards to
kids entertainment but I have been
excited for a trailer for this because
this whole franchise is taking something
that should not work and making it work
and oftentimes sequels to kids films do
not work well show me how you gonna make
it work and when it started I got
nervous cuz it started all like Grimm
and Mad Max II and you know the with
with Lucy wyldstyle I'll just call her
Lucy cuz because that seems to be what
she's going by now but you know looking
out and talking about the horror that
was rocked and I'm like I I don't know
how to feel about this yet because it
hadn't been going on long enough for me
to to like clue in out where was about
to go
but then of course there's Emmett
ordinariness coffee walking down the
street Oh Thank You Emmett thank you
because that is everything right there
that is that is exactly what I want out
of the lego movie this overarching story
elements of witches taking us up
completely seriously but with these
characters that are like this and just
throw the whole thing out of whack in a
good way
and I'd so I got that and then I was
just smooth sailing from there I like a
lot of what I see in this I like all the
characters I see who are returning
almost nobody gets highlighted
aside from Emmett and Lucy which I
actually think is really good because
this gives us I at least I feel a fairly
decent sense of story especially for our
first trailer like a teaser trailer but
it gives us really a sense of where
these characters are at which i think is
the best thing that a sequel trailer can
give you don't bog us out on what the
next plot thing is like how are these
characters and do they feel like this is
where they should be based off where
they were last time we saw them and it's
all spot-on as far as that is concerned
but I also really like all the other
characters who I spotted even though
they didn't do much so I saw unikitty
and Batman and Benny the space man and
I'm pretty sure it's a metal beard so
I'm like everybody's back makes me happy
and I'm so on board for this there are I
think I'm probably and I can't imagine
that I'm the I'm like breaking the code
and figuring this out but I'm gonna put
a potential spoiler warning because I'm
about to speculate something that is
into that I think pretty clearly but is
not made explicit in the trailer so if
you're worried about hearing a bit of
speculation and having part of the movie
ruined for you as a result just know
that I really like this trailer and
bhayya see another time for those of you
have stuck around so I think I figured
out the meta plot on this which is that
the sister
of the boy that we saw last time I don't
think she got a name I think she was
just your your sister and she would have
been the head of the duplo invasion but
I mean I think that we are looking at a
real time passage of time that this is
several years later both the in universe
just as it's several years later for us
and so the result of that is the sisters
a little bit older and what she's doing
is kidnapping the Lego toys that she
wants to bring to thee as it gets
pronounced sis star system so I think
that I think the meta gag on this is
that you have this sister cherry picking
what she thinks is really cool including
figuring out like Lucy did way more
stuff than Emmett did and going yeah I'm
taking you and which I like I like all
that and funnily enough this it was
really weird watching this after
wreck-it Ralph come out because it does
almost the exact same joke that earth to
me in that one the whole guy came in to
get the credit for the thing the girls
did joke and that annoyed me in the
wreck-it ralph trailer but I liked it
here which I think points to a couple of
things first it quite possibly
emphasizes how much I sour the record
after the instant I saw the Disney all
the Disney properties so it was like
digital Disneyworld because if that if
that joke in that trailer hadn't been
hadn't followed that may be able to
liked it better but I still think I
would have liked this better because
this matches the tone of the Lego movies
because this level of meta wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute kind of joke
is that's what the lego movie is like
whereas it felt much more crowbarred in
and turn especially for how long it
seemed to go on for that joke in the
wreckit-ralph trailer so again it kind
of illustrates how I can I can
appreciate what is the core idea of a
joking concept but it's still possible
to screw up the delivery of that joke at
least for me in one way
another I think there might be all I
really have to say it's funny when I get
real what I really like this stuff I
tend to make short videos cuz there
isn't always more to say then I liked it
yeah uh-huh and I did there's really I
don't think I even have nitpicks on this
really I'm I'm completely on board I'm
excited for it I want to see what it's
got you know up its sleeve because the
the first lego movie was was a whole
mess of awesome concepts and and
well-executed gags and ideas and
characters and and I am excited to go
back into this into this world again and
be with these characters again so yeah
the lego movie 2 the second part first
trailer have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever your thoughts
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there's all the
stuff to do such as like and subscribe
to support me on patreon follow me on
Twitter buy a t-shirt links for all that
stuff and more that I didn't even
mention is down in the description so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]